You are one of 7.6 billion people on
this earth, but what does that mean?
How can those 10 digits properly
reflect the size of our species?
Can we truly grasp our impact on this
planet currently to better understand our
presence on earth?
We consider a variety of statistics like
how many cars are on the road at once
or how many emails are sent per day of
maybe it would tell us more to take all
that away.
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if all humans
suddenly disappeared from the earth.
The second humans disappear from
Earth. Chaos ensues. Planes, trains,
and automobiles without drivers would
collide, derail and tumble out of the sky.
Within the first hour, massive blackouts
would start to occur across the globe.
Electricity generated from coal plants
would fail once their fuel rat out,
while wind and water powered systems
would also shut down without human
supervision.
The next day,
computers would act on their own
accord to shut down nuclear reactors.
In order to prevent disaster. The world
would be completely without power,
but nuclear crises would at
least be temporarily averted.
On Day three.
London's Big Ben Rings for the last time
since it needs to be wound every three
days. Big Ben would sound over streets
now populated with roaming animals.
Thousands of pets and zoo creatures
would have to break free or suffer
starvation within 10 days.
Security measures in nuclear
power plants would finally fail.
Setting off a chain of
explosions and releasing toxic
radiation across the globe.
Wildlife in affected regions would die,
but elsewhere.
Other species would prevail.
Domesticated cattle and livestock would
take to the North American great plains
where they could graze freely.
Supermarkets would be infested with
mice and rats and former pets would turn
feral in their bid for survival.
Within a few years,
the city's we so easily recognized today
would look like converted natural theme
parks.
Nuclear radiation would have cleared and
vegetation with sprout across the urban
sprawl.
Moss would overtake the streets while
trees and flowers would travel up at along
abandoned towers.
After 30 years,
the satellites we set up to explore would
fall back down to earth with no one to
collect their data.
Homes and skyscrapers,
we'll have rotted or collapsed
in some coastal areas.
Entire cities will have been
reclaimed by the sea and old ships.
Sunk or ran aground would be the
foundation of new coral reefs.
Despite our absence,
global warming would continue for
another 40 years after we're gone.
The Earth's temperature would
rise about another 0.6 degrees,
but the environment would nonetheless
be improving drastically by your 64 real
life would have nearly recovered from
decades of over fishing and will be
thriving in 150 years.
Urban environments would be restored to
their natural status. Before human time,
London would revert to swamp land and
in northern cities like Vancouver,
skeletons of buildings would poke out
from layer upon layer of snow and ice.
Las Vegas might look like a
giant sand castle in 230 years.
Vegetation that has thrived and humans
absence will have eliminated excess
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere.
Huge forest will have reclaimed
the eastern half of North America,
and the only evidence we ever existed,
it would be leftover steel and plastics.
Once glorious landmarks would
slowly succumb to decay.
500 years after humans disappeared,
the world's forests would
be the healthiest that
they've been in 10,000 years.
The natural world would have succeeded
in a racing most of the final traces of
human existence. Of course,
even after 25,000 years,
some of our plastic objects might still
be found along with everything we've
left on past trips to the moon.
So if you've ever wondered what it means
to be one of the 7.6 billion people on
this earth than think of it this way,
it would take more than 25,000 years to
hide the fact that we were ever here.
Our domination of the land
is huge and incredible.
And while humans might not
disappear into thin air,
we shouldn't take our planet for granted.
How will you help to make
our world a better place?